Metal Gear Solid crater Hideo Kojima has
responded to Konami Metal Gear survived
the first new game in the series
following his departure from the company
last year I'm Lucy and welcome to your
mech cellent games bar news update
according to IGN Kojima was asked if the
idea for survive came from his mind he
said that's nothing to do with me he
went on to call out the game's use of
zombies
he said the Metal Gear games are about
political fiction and espionage where
does aam be fit in with that he did say
however that had he worked on Metal Gear
survive it might be different if I had
worked on that game it would have mix in
it Metal Gear survived was announced
during Gamescom in August it's a
multiplayer stealth game coming to Xbox
one ps4 and PC in 2017 the spin-off is
set in the same universe as Metal Gear
Solid 5 and takes place after the events
of ground zeroes Konami said that Metal
Gear survive will not cost $60 instead
it will be somewhere in the vicinity of
what Ground zeroes cost at launch which
was 30 bucks so what do you make of
Metal Gear survive you still interested
in the series even though Kojima is no
longer involved with it let me know in
the comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on Metal Gear and Hideo Kojima make sure
you keep it GameSpot
you
[Music]